[Music]  [Music]  seek  what do you shelter immediately is no  idea  the only thing people want to talk about  today is this interstellar comet called  clark  is saying it appeared out of nowhere  from like a different solar system  this is the fragment entering the lower  atmosphere three  two one an impact where's the explosion  it's a chunk of rock rocks don't explode  yeah tell that to the dinosaurs  the sky's on fire come on let's go  with the largest fragment expected to  hit in less than 24 hours  space agencies are expecting an  extinction-level event  the greatest chance of survival there  are the bunkers in greenland  [Music]  we're gonna go gotta go now okay  [Music]  you're such a brave guy you know that i  swear  greenland rigged pg-13 on demand  everywhere december 18th  [Music]  you